è il cuore batte perché perché abbiamo
percorso una strada e non è mai una
strada d'asfalto la nostra è una strada
fatta di persone e le persone ti fanno
battere il cuore e siamo arrivati qui in
pochi rispetto a tutti quelli che ci
hanno accompagnato in quest'ultima metrò
al walk in salento è però il cuore di
tutti e qui e ve lo racconteremo e un
cuore che che sa di comunità operosa ed
è un cuore che sa di persone che
decidono di restare la natural walk e
una strada collettiva condivisa è un
modo per rendere rivoluzionaria
un'esperienza che non è fatta di piedi
che camminano e si mettono a macinare
chilometri è una strada fatta di cuori
di storie e di racconti e di tanto
ascolto ed è una strada intrapresa tre
anni fa e abbiamo iniziato a camminare
con casa network perché volevamo dar
voce ai paesi invisibili e alle storie
che credevano di non essere interessanti
invece erano molto interessanti ed erano
anche molto emozionanti e avevano anche
tanto da insegnarci
abbiamo percorso 200 più di 250 km
abbiamo incontrato centinaia di persone
e circa una quarantina di paesi abbiamo
incrociato e tantissime storie ma
stasera la metro al work ve la vogliamo
raccontare con le persone che l'hanno
abitata in quest'ultima esperienza in
salento un salento diverso che ci ha
profondamente emozionato un salento non
fatto di mare di ombrelloni e sdraio un
salento fatto di bellissime storie di
tanto coraggio e
dei volti delle persone che sono qui con
noi le persone che hanno fondato il
laboratorio rurale luna a galatone le
donne di luna ne andiamo orgogliosi
la masseria protocollo che ci ha
ospitato gli orti sinergici stai
terraterra stai sinergico marta e le sue
vigne la la bellezza dell'accoglienza
del sentirsi a casa e vogliamo
raccontarvi la forza rivoluzionaria di
una network dando voce a quelli che sono
gli ingredienti di una natural walk e lo
faremo facendovi salire sul nostro
trenino abbiamo preso le ferrovie sud
est ha anche e abbiamo provato
l'emozione di camminare lenti in un
paesaggio mozzafiato lane prova che
tante cose e ora
oggi diamo voce a tutte queste cose
insieme
sì la natural walk e immaginazione e
camminare e immaginare per me e anche
fotografare fotografando guardo spesso
quello che i camminanti ai camminatori
si scambiano durante il nostro viaggio
durante l'attraversamento di questi
territori e immaginare significa anche
connettere o cercare di riconnettere
esperienze e saperi sapori di una terra
e quindi immaginarla il con occhi nuovi
la retro walk e un incontro e per me è
stato l'incontro con chiara che
nell'ultima dopo l'ultima camminata
fatta tra la basilicata e la calabria ha
deciso di trasferirsi a matera sì sono
io chiara anche per me la la parola
chiave della natural volk è stato
incontro e incontro innanzitutto con
con me stessa nel senso che ho ascoltato
quello che era un mio bisogno del
momento cioè quello di vedere occhi
nuovi di incontrare gente nuova di
vedere paesaggi nuovi perché sono
appunto di milano quindi una realtà per
me nuova questa e
è questa quindi questo ascoltarmi mi ha
consentito poi invece di aprirmi anche
con con gli altri quindi con l'incontro
con tantissime altre persone e sono
stati degli incontri molto forti
ad esempio in questa network il mio
ricordo va a jolanda che è una ragazza
super energica e che quindi è in lei io
mi sono un po rivista e quindi è bello
anche quando ci si incontra magari per
la prima volta ma si riconosce
nell'altro una parte di sé e quindi e lo
si segue così e si va
e poi sono stati anche incontri magari
invece più delicati e se penso a
stamattina all'incontro con il contadino
tonino lui proprio ci ha fatto entrare
così spontaneamente tra ii suoi kaki
mela e poi è stato divertentissimo ci ha
raccontato barzellette ma proprio con
una spontaneità molto molto fresca e e
poi ci sono anche stati però incontri
anche silenziosi quindi dove dove basta
anche cioè dove si sta ci si guarda e si
sta così in ascolto se
ci si guarda moltissimo sì devo dire
proprio questo è e poi coraggio quindi
al quel punto si parte quando ho
lasciato parigi non sapevo nulla del sud
dell'italia e quindi questa esperienza è
stata un occasione di incontrare delle
persone che non fanno le cose perché
sono figlie perché è di moda di fare
impresa però delle persone che che hanno
passioni che ci credono che vogliono
fare bene e soprattutto che vogliono
condividere con gli amici
quindi abbiamo incontrati delle persone
con un coraggio stupendo e il coraggio
che che di andare al oltre oltre la
pressione sociale oltre la pressione
familiare e quindi il modo adesso in cui
voglio lavorare qui è nato il mio sogno
la natural walk e anche far parte far
parte significa entrare nei luoghi sulla
punta dei piedi e anche perdere tutti i
tipi di inibizione come potete vedere da
questa immagine significa raccontarsi e
ascoltare raccontare gli altri significa
condividere molte cose e significa anche
andare a collaborare nelle attività
quotidiane delle realtà che incontriamo
significa andare a piedi far parte e
andare a piedi e usare soltanto mezzi
locali mezzi pubblici come le ferrovie
del sud est e significa ascoltare
parlare il dialetto e far finta di
capire significa anche far parte
significa soprattutto essere dalla parte
di chi ha deciso di non andare ma di
restare arrivare nei luoghi con una m al
walk significa
innanzitutto accoglienza significa
sentirsi a casa
arriviamo in silenzio solitamente non
annunciamo con strombazzamenti il nostro
arrivo
e arriviamo in ascolto e le persone ci
accolgono sempre ci accolgono sempre non
c'è mai nessuno che ci chiude la porta
c'è sempre gente che si unisce contadini
che ci vogliono raccontare per strada
che cosa stanno coltivando che ci
regalano chili di frutta che poi non
possiamo portare nello zaino e quindi
camminare in una network è la cosa più
rivoluzionaria che si possa fare perché
in fondo camminare è una metafora della
vita e una grande rivoluzione
rivoluzione fuori dal ma soprattutto
rivoluzione dentro di sé abbiamo
raccontato l'ultimo cammino di network
in salento utilizzando degli hashtag
perché la natural walk e tradizione
innovazione e viene raccontata in
diretta se senza ma consulte rete questi
astag sui sui social network voi
troverete il racconto di tutto quello
che abbiamo vissuto delle emozioni dei
volti delle persone e avrete voglia di
visitare questi luoghi in una nuova
chiave di non passare di fermarvi
parlare condividere e vedrete che anche
raccontare a signor antonio che stiamo
andando alte dx è che una bella emozione
ed invitarlo sarà veramente tanto tanto
rivoluzionario adesso vi lasciamo con
una pillola una pillola di una della
nostra network estiva perché vogliamo
che tiriate tutti un bel respiro e vi
immergete per un minuto in una vera
camminata rivoluzionaria
nella nostra m al volto grazie
sbaglia
oma 20 dic
la mia
il tumore